[Musique]
le
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec un mec
côté thibault inox bon gentil bonjour
orione est notre invité cette semaine et
hervé marseille bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes sénateur des
hauts-de-seine et vous êtes également le
président du groupe centriste au sénat
et au menu de cette semaine la réforme
constitutionnelle elle a été adopté en
commission à l'assemblée de nombreux
points comme la réforme de la procédure
parlementaire ont suscité de vifs débats
une ministre qui changent d'avis ce
n'est pas si courant la secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'égalité homme femme
marlène schiappa est revenu sur une
mesure de la loi sur les violences
sexuelles lors de son examen au sénat
elle a suivi l'avis des sénateurs et des
associations des forces de l'ordre au
bord de la crise de nerfs ce sont les
conclusions d'un rapport sénatorial qui
a fait grand bruit cette semaine la
sueur mobilisation lié à la menace
terroriste est une des causes avancées
mais pas la seule enfin la loi sur la
manipulation de l'information elle est
adoptée à l'assemblée cette semaine
elle doit permettre de mettre fin à la
diffusion de fausses nouvelles en
particulier pendant les périodes
électorales
quand on commence cette semaine avec
elles la réforme constitutionnelle qui a
entamé son parcours parlementaire
[Musique]
la route est encore très longue pour
cette réforme de la constitution voulue
par emmanuel macron mais une première
étape a donc été franchie le texte a été
adopté en commission des lois à
l'assemblée ce lundi les débats ont été
intenses présageant ceux qui auront lieu
dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée à partir
de mardi prochain
le résumé est signée nathalie gloire qui
et pour qui est contre je vous remercie
il est donc adoptée après 40 heures de
discussions et plus de 1300 amendement
débattu le projet de loi
constitutionnelle est adopté en
commission des lois
dès les premières heures de débat les
députés ont adopté un amendement très
symbolique
ils ont supprimé à l'unanimité le mot
race de l'article 1er je crois que là on
marque notre notre volonté de supprimer
définitivement la notion même qu'il y
aurait plusieurs races et si tous se
sont félicités de voir le mot supprimé
de la constitution il faudra encore
attendre pour décider d'un nouveau terme
pour le remplacer les députés ont
également acté l'inscription dans la
constitution de la préservation de
l'environnement et de la diversité
biologique ainsi que l'action contre le
changement climatique
cette inscription aura et sa réponse aux
nombreuses questions
une portée symbolique et normative plus
importante que la seule modification de
l'article 34 une semaine de débat
marathon aux commissions parfois
ponctuées par des échanges tendus
notamment sur le temps de parole des
députés une révision de la constitution
implique implique la souveraineté oui
les parlementaires que nous sommes et
implique qu'on nous prenne le temps
qu'il faut pour un texte qui engage
enfin qui engage la république
au bout de deux minutes au lieu d'une
parce que deux amendements c'est pas
scandaleuse tour demandent les élus de
l'opposition comptent une victoire dans
l'examen de ce texte faute de majorité
ils ont rejeté vendredi la restriction
du droit d'amendement
un des articles et du projet de révision
constitutionnelle l'impression qu'on
veut transformer le parlement du simple
chambre d'enregistrement est engagé dans
une stratégie de cadenassage de l'action
parlementaire c'est une erreur
monumentale
le texte sera débattu en séance publique
à partir du mardi 18
alors c'est gérard larcher le président
du sénat dit que le texte n'est pas
acceptable en l'état est-ce que c'est
aussi votre avis oui le texte n'est pas
acceptable en l'état
c'est pour ça qu'on va le discuter nous
sommes favorables à ce qu'ils aient une
réforme de la constitution mais pas que
la constitution il ya la loi organique
et la loi simple c'est assez complexe
mais il faut en discuter notamment sur
ce qui ce qu'on appelle la fabrique de
la loi c'est-à-dire les conditions dans
lesquelles on vote la loi
et le bicaméralisme avec les commissions
mixtes paritaires le droit d'amendement
pour chaque parlementaire
tout ça va faire l'objet de discussions
ici d'abord à l'assemblée nationale et
puis ensuite au sénat à l'automne
le président du groupe la république en
marche à l'assemblée richard ferrand a
déclaré jeudi que sauf mauvaise foi je
le cite de la part des sénateurs les
deux chambres devraient pouvoir aboutir
un accord commun est-ce que ça
sous-entend qu'il craint que le sénat ne
fasse échouer la réforme pour des
raisons politiques
écoutez j'ai lu effectivement les propos
du président ferrand je pense pas qu'il
soit de mauvaise foi lui lui non plus
quand
il évoque un certain nombre de sujets
dans les textes tout le monde veut me
semble-t-il aller au compromis
je parle les groupes raisonnable il ya
des groupes effectivement où le front
national au les insoumis qui en d'autres
options mais entre la république en
marche une partie des républicains les
centristes je crois qu'il ya une volonté
discuter de dialoguer trouver les bons
dispositif et moi je suis confiant je
suis confiant on a au début du processus
puisqu'il va être long 1 le président de
la république a dit le gouvernement a
dit d'ici 2019
donc ça laisse du temps on est en
première lecture à l'assemblée y avoir
une lecture au sénat puis ensuite on il
va y avoir une première lecture
concernant les textes organiques et loi
simple c'est à dire c'est pas rien le
nombre de parlementaires les territoires
et puis ça va venir au sénat aussi donc
il ya le temps de discuter mais on
connaît un les thèmes qui importe au
sénat est ce que vous jugez vous que
lors de ces quarante heures de débats en
commission les députés ont fait des
passes suffisant vers le sénat ba déjà
ils n'ont pas diverger ce qui est et ce
qui est bien parce qu'on pouvait
s'attendre à tout un
on avait vu passer des amendements je
veux dire la constitution c'est pas le
règlement intérieur d'un club de
football
on mais pas n'importe quoi dans
l'article 1
la biodiversité les transgenres pas quoi
on a vu passer toutes sortes de choses
tout ça est déraisonnable donc on a
introduit par exemple des notions
environnementales à cet article 1
il faut là aussi être prudent pourquoi
pas on n'est pas hostile à l'idée
il faut être prudent parce que derrière
on sait très bien qu'il peut y avoir
tout un tas de décret de theix
législatives qui vont à l'encontre du
développement économique ou du
développement agricole
on l'a vu et que le sacro saint principe
de précaution et on a vu où ça pouvait
mener donc d'un principe qui est
partagée qui est un bon principe on peut
avoir toutes sortes de développement qui
après compliquer la vie des agriculteurs
des chefs d'entreprise il faut être
prudent sur ce qu'on met dans la
constitution art ya eu un vote surprise
pendant ces débats la majorité s'est
trouvée prise en défaut sur l'article 3
qui a été repoussée c'est l'encadrement
du droit d'amendement
vous possédez penser aussi qu'il
faudrait purement et simplement revenir
sur cette idée oublier août et le droit
d'amendement
la façon dont il est utilisé pas la même
au sénat et à l'assemblée nationale
donc je crois et au sénat nous pensons
que il appartient à chaque règlement
intérieur à l'assemblée au sénat aussi
d'adapter en fonction de la culture de
chaque assemblée
la façon dont on traite le les
amendements c'est vrai que qu'au sénat
on est un peu plus restrictif
on a des méthodes qui permettent de
faire des amendements tout en n'étant
pas excessif et un arbitrage qui se fait
avec les présidents de commissions donc
l'article 41 articles 45 nous on a déjà
une utilisation rationnelle de tout ça
aman rapidement sur le congrès qui aura
lieu lundi emmanuel macron s'exprimera
devant sénateurs et députés réunis
il fera le bilan de sa première année du
quinquennat tracera les perspectives
pour l'année suivante
mais il ne pourra pas entendre les
discours des parlementaires ni leur
réponse est constitué d'un
constitutionnellement impossible
est-ce qu'il faut changer la
constitution pour que cela devienne
possible moi c'est une idée que j'avais
on peut en parler c'est vrai que au
parlement européen par exemple président
de la république quand il y va il peut
rester pour écouter les orateurs
là c'est un peu solennel déjà grâce à
nicolas sarkozy le président peut venir
devant les parlementaires il pouvait
aller devant le congrès des états unis
mais ils pouvaient pas venir devant les
parlementaires français
donc grâce à la réforme de 2008 le
président peut venir
maintenant il part après son discours et
tout le monde
enfin chaque groupe s'exprime
et tout ça est un peu comment dire
formelle surtout moi ça me choquerait
pas qu'ils puissent rester maintenant
c'est vrai institutionnellement certains
puristes de la vème république craignent
que le président puisse être mis en
cause par les parlementaires et qu'il
puisse y avoir une forme de
responsabilité du président alors
qu'elle n'existe pas devant le parlement
je crois qu'on peut essayer de trouver
une écriture qui permettrait que le
président puisse rester et entendre ce
qui lui répondent
allez on verra ça lundi et vous pourrez
suivre évidemment l'intégralité du
congrès sur les chaînes parlementaires
place à notre deuxième thème la loi sur
les violences sexuelles et sexistes
adopté jeudi par le sénat présomption de
contrainte en cas d'abus sexuels sur
mineurs obligation pour les médecins de
signaler les violences sur mineur
pénalisation de la drogue du viol voici
les principaux apport du sénat le
gouvernement a quant à lui retirer une
disposition polémique
le délit d'atteinte sexuelle avec
pénétration permettant un juge de
requalifier un viols en délits un
travail sénatorial salué par la garde
des sceaux nicole belloubet je dois tout
d'abord insister comme l'a fait ma
collègue à l'instant sur la particulière
qualité du travail qui a été conduit par
la commission des lois qui s'explique
notamment par l'intérêt que la haute
assemblée porte depuis plusieurs années
à la question des violences sexuelles
commises sur les femmes sur les enfants
à marseille dès le début de l'examen du
texte le gouvernement a donc retiré sa
disposition polémique le délit
d'atteinte sexuelle avec pénétration est
ce que c'est une bonne chose
oui c'est une bonne chose devront se
prouve que le sénat est utile on a parlé
de la constitution
le bicaméralisme montre et affirme son
intérêt certains pouvaient en douter
je crois qu'une fois de plus on voit que
le travail entre les deux chambres est
un échange utile est saluée d'ailleurs
par par le gouvernement sur un sujet qui
est un sujet difficile et à l'évidence
il ya eu des débats au qui était parfois
un peu passionné parce qu'on touche au
plus profond de la conviction de chacun
mais à la fin on a trouvé une forme de
notes unanimité importante puisque le
texte est adopté par près de 200 voix
voilà ce qui montre quand même qu' il y
avait une démarche assez partagés sur le
travail qui a été fait et donc après de
longs débats qui ont parfois été
c'est vrai un peu un peu difficile mais
très important et très intéressante et
constructif
j'allais dire le gouvernement a reconnu
et une large majorité du sénat ont
reconnu que le texte de la commission
des lois était le bon texte alors
abandonné cette peine d'atteintes
sexuelles avec une et rations c'est une
chose mais par quoi faudrait-il la
remplacer ce qu'il faut revenir sur
l'idée initiale d'un nage en deçà duquel
tout acte sexuel est considéré comme un
viol
et quel âge serait le bon alors certains
ont défendu l'âge de 13 ans en disant
voilà présomption irréfragable
bon je vois pas refaire le débat il a
été tranché on a allongé les délais de
prescription 30 ans je crois que c'était
important il ya un certain nombre
d'autres rapports qui ont été faits vous
les avez signalé ce qu'il fallait éviter
c'était effectivement la correctionnelle
la correctionnalisation du délit et la
crainte qu'on pouvait avoir que tout ça
soit requalifié le fait que le garde des
sceaux ait retiré sa proposition à
permet de trouver un large consensus et
je crois que maintenant quand elle parle
d'un texte extrêmement protecteur elle a
raison ça va assez loin pour extrêmement
on verra un usage il est davantage
protecteur on a pris des précautions
maintenant on fait confiance aussi au
juge qu'ils vont appliquer ces textes
pour avoir le bon discernement sur
l'application du texte alors autre sujet
en cette semaine a été publié un rapport
sénatorial alarmant sur l'état des
forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rythme de travail pénibles moyens
insuffisants des motivations et
découragement pour la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale et c'est une
véritable crise que traversent les
gendarmes et les policiers
un malaise renforcé par l'exposition
croissante à la violence et à la menace
terroriste fabien becker après six mois
d'enquêté les sénateurs dresse un
tableau plus qu'alarmant de l'état des
forces de sécurité premier indice du mal
être un taux de suicide parmi les forces
de l'ordre supérieur de 36% à la moyenne
nationale en 2017
cinquante policiers se sont donné la
mort le rapport pointe aussi la
pénibilité des rythmes de travail
les policiers ne passeraient en moyenne
qu'un week-end sur 4 ou sur cinq avec
leurs familles et accumulent les heures
supplémentaires
le rapport en comptabilise à ce jour
près de 22 millions ni récupérer ni
rémunéré un niveau jamais atteint 21,8
millions d'heures supplémentaires qui ne
sont pas payés et dont personne ne sait
comment on va les payer et aucune autre
administration qu'une collectivité
aucune entreprise qui pourrait se
permettre cela
et le malaise des forces de l'ordre
s'alimente aussi des difficultés
quotidiennes comme le vieillissement
voire le manque de matériel 10% du parc
automobile à plus de dix ans le rapport
décrit des sirènes qui ne fonctionnent
plus ou des portes coulissantes qui ne
ferme pas et les conditions de vie des
policiers se dégrade
l'offre de logement en particulier pour
les jeunes policiers affectés en région
parisienne serait très insuffisante
prend même pas en considération leur
situation familiale
ils peuvent être mariés avoir avoir une
compagne avoir des enfants et les
conditions sur vraiment mais déplorable
déplorable face à l'épuisement
professionnel des policiers des
gendarmes
les sénateurs font 32 propositions parmi
lesquelles la rédaction d'un livre blanc
sur l'emploi des forces de sécurité et
l'inscription de mesures prioritaires
dans la prochaine loi de finances hervé
marseille est ce que l'état a réellement
pris la mesure de cette crise est de ce
malaise des forces de l'ordre non je
crois que ce rapport est assez exhaustif
il montre un état préoccupant des forces
de police et moi je veux rendre hommage
aux deux policiers qui ont été roués de
coups et a malheureusement quelques
quelques heures quelques jours je crois
qu'on vient de céder et l'arrestation
d'un des agresseurs il faut que la
justice maintenant sévices on voit bien
que il n'y a plus d'interdît
on va chercher les policiers chez eux
pour se venger de ce qu'ils ont pu faire
ils sont face au terrorisme se souvient
de l'assassinât de ses deux policiers à
magnanville ils sont totalement exposés
personnellement on voit les problèmes
sociaux où il faut faire face
j'allais dire au cortège ou difficultés
sociales il ya les problèmes migratoires
qui mobilise beaucoup de policiers
également aux frontières et à tous les
problèmes d'ordre public
tout ça fait qu'il ya une exaspération
pas ce qu'on leur demande beaucoup et on
n'a pas parlé dans ce rapport
malheureusement
de quelque chose qui fait sujet
également dans les hôpitaux c'est les 35
heures le statut horaires des policiers
fait qu' il faut beaucoup de policiers
et que même si il en manque
il faut en embaucher des efforts ont été
faits sur le plan budgétaire il faut les
former avant qu'ils arrivent sur sur le
terrain il ya un vrai malaise 22
millions on vient de dire 22 millions
d'heures supplémentaires non payées
pasta vrai c'est un vrai problème ils
sont fatigués ils sont exaspérés et
quand la police d'un pays est dans cet
état c'est préoccupant parce que la
police c'est ce qui permet de maintenir
l'ordre dans la société d'être un
rempart face aux dérives et on a besoin
d'avoir une police qui soit solide
on a vu à notre dame des landes les
forces de l'ordre exposé dangereusement
face à des manifestants armés parfois
hier à nantes
on a vu encore les débordements un
policier a pris une balle de 22 long
rifle dans son casque enfin on est
maintenant à un niveau de dangerosité
pour la police qui est extrêmement
préoccupant alors on en vient à notre
quatrième thème la loi sur les fausses
informations
[Musique]
protection contre des atteintes à la
démocratie pour les uns dangereuse
tentative d'édicter une vérité d'état
pour les autres la loi sur la
manipulation de l'information a suscité
de vifs débats à l'assemblée elle a fait
finalement été adopté par 52 voix pour
et 22 voix contre félix ul comment
définir une fausse information
le débat a agité l'hémicycle et la
définition retenue et finalement celle
ci toute allégation ou imputation d'un
fait inexactes ou trompeuses inexactes
pour qui pour les journalistes de
libération
donc en réalité se dessine au fur et à
mesure des débats une loi qui est une
vraie loi de censure des opinions
les débats ont également porté sur la
question des périodes électorales
le texte voté prévoit en effet que juste
avant les élections
lorsqu'un candidat ou un parti se
considère comme victime de fausses
informations sur internet
il pourra saisir un juge des référés
si les informations sont de mauvaise foi
et diffuser de manière massive
alors le juge pourra ordonner la
fermeture des sites internet concernés
vous allez donc demander à un juge en
quelques minutes en quelques heures dans
la précipitation de déterminer c'est
quelque chose est vraie ou pas le juge
sera parfaitement juger ce qui est du
relève de l'argutie politique et de la
manipulation d'informations
j'ai envie de dire industrialisés
automatisé et de masse autres
dispositions du texte la surveillance
des médias étrangers
le csa aura la possibilité de suspendre
les chaînes y est à des états étrangers
si celle-ci perturbent gravement la vie
de la nation
en ligne de mire les médias russes moi
je ne suis pas d'accord pour que le
président du csa décide si la russie est
votre partenaire ou notre ennemi de quel
droit un organe administrative
va-t-il prendre des décisions de
géopolitique tout ça est absurde
à la fin du mois ce sera au tour du
sénat de débattre du texte ça une
majorité du groupe centriste à
l'assemblée a voté contre ce texte
il en sera de même au sénat écoutez j'ai
vu devoir se passionnait pas les foules
cinquante cinq pour 20 contre sur 577
députés
faible mobilisation non c'est un texte
bidon et je pense qu'au sénat je suis
même pas sûr que on examine ce texte
dans tous les cas moi je propose est
vraiment groupe j'en ai parlé avec
catherine morin desailly qui préside la
commission de la culture et qui examine
ce texte qui regarde ça avec beaucoup de
réserve
si on va aller jusqu'au bout de la
discussion parce que ce texte est est
pas au point
on voit bien qu'il appelle beaucoup
d'interrogations et en tous les cas pour
ce qui est de mon groupe je suis pas sûr
que l'on ne propose pas de refuser de le
discuter parce que on va pas perdre de
temps
à discuter d'un texte qui est pas au
point et qui ne peut-être de bon pour de
bon diagnostic
encore une fois il ya un sujet
maintenant les réponses qui sont
apportées sont pas au niveau et chacun
l'a dit est ce qu'il n'ya pas même un
risque d'effets pervers de la loi qui
pourrait même légitimer une fausse
information si le fameux juge des
référés qui ne disposera que de 48
heures ne trouve pas les éléments pour
l'interdire et puis il va y avoir des
référés en pagaille on va
arrivé à une thrombose du référé sur ces
sujets là tout le monde vous leur faire
des référés effectivement le revers de
la médaille c'est que si vous obtenez
pas satisfaction
on va donner le sentiment que ce qui est
écrit ou dit est vrai sans préjudice des
autres observations celle de de mon
collègue monsieur mélenchon évidemment
mais pas dénué de pertinence de quel
droit le csa qui est une autorité
administrative peut prendre des
décisions à caractère politique bon on
n'habite pas au point on a bien compris
votre position hervé marseille on va
maintenant passer à la partie politique
de cette émission avec notre partenaire
du figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous accueillons sur ce plateau jean
ferrat c'est aujourd'hui
bonjour hervé marseille bonjour on a
appris jeudi le report du plan pauvreté
qui devait être annoncé la semaine
prochaine pour cause nous a dit agnès
buzyn de collision avec l'actualité
footballistique
en réalité le plan a priori n'est pas
complètement bouclés est ce que c'est un
retard un report regrettable
oui c'est un report regrettable ce qui
est regrettable aussi c'est
l'explication de madame du zinc est au
demeurant quelqu'un de respectable et
qui fait bien son travail mais je crois
que elle a dit la vérité
un peu vite en disant les français
s'intéressent davantage au football
qu'au congrès à ce qui va être fait dans
les jours qui viennent
je pense quand même qu'il ya un vrai
problème dans la politique sociale du
gouvernement
tu passes à la lire il ya déjà un
problème de méthode ont créé des
commissions sur le déficit qu'à 22 sur
les retraites avec monsieur delevoye
il ya toutes sortes de haut-commissaire
on connaît même plus leur nom
donc on demande à des gens de faire de
la concertation et d'apporter des
propositions et puis entre temps le
gouvernement décide on n'attend pas le
rapport de loi sur les retraites qu'on
parle déjà des pensions de réversion aux
log allemand qui a été enterrée est ce
que l ou lens-bordeaux c'est pire que ça
et il a été humilié louis borloo parce
que la façon dont on a traité jean louis
borloo est pas est pas admissible que tu
dire on peut contester son travail on
peut le discuter
on lui a demandé un rapport et après on
l'a envoyé balader dans les termes que
vous savez donc sur le social il faut
accélérer d'urgence oui oui il ya il ya
un vrai problème dans la dimension
sociale songez que on a touché aux apl
le gouvernement a fini par reconnaître
qu'il avait fait une erreur ce n'est pas
rien bon il ya des millions de gens qui
touchent l'apl
il ya la cg pour les personnes
retraitées là avec la loi est là on est
en train de toucher au logement social
une privatisation rampante
avec des effets capitalistique qui vont
avoir vous attendez séquences vous
attendez en mode emmanuel macron sur le
sujet lundi au congrès n'ont pas
seulement un mot des annonces parce que
qu'on reporte un certain nombre
d'annoncés plan pauvreté pourquoi pas je
veux dire on peut considérer que la
période n'est pas la meilleure que il
faut encore travailler qu'il faut
dialoguer mais il faut à tout prix
donner une dimension sociale à l'action
de ce gouvernement
elle est où l'action sociale elle est où
et est donc c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai
déficit social et qui creusent davantage
le fossé avec notamment les territoires
de province avec les petites villes or
justement les associations l'après cette
semaine les associations représentatives
des communes des régions des
départements a annoncé qu'elle allait
boycotter la conférence de territoire du
12 juillet est-ce que voilà la rupture
est consommée entre le gouvernement et
les territoires oui c'est pas nouveau
parce que là encore on a créé une
conférence des territoires et ont fait
un tas d'annoncés sans attendre le
résultat des échanges et du dialogue
avec ses avions que vous disiez d'un
problème de la méthode il ya des
annonces il ya des revirements
tout ça est extrêmement préjudiciable
et là encore on touche au social une
commune ou un département qui par
définition avec compétence sociale
si vous lui ait coupé ses moyens c'est
pas un problème d'argent soit vous dit
voilà il ya moins d'argent et et vous en
aurez moins derrière tout ça c'est le
service apporté à la population dans
votre commune si vos enfants vont à la
cantine le midi
la collectivité doit pas pouvoir mettre
tout l'argent qu'elle mettait pour
compenser et faire en sorte que le prix
soit bas pour les crèches pourraient
handicaper pour ceux ci pour cela c'est
qu'est-ce que vous pouvoir faire les
collectivités pour aider les familles
les gens vont de plus en plus payer le
coût le prix du service et donc
socialement ça va être encore un effet
supplémentaire
dernière question peut-être sur les
européennes les partis sont en train de
constituer des listes est ce que lui dit
va présenter une liste indépendante en
partant seul sens
la république en marche européenne
écouter aujourd'hui la république en
marche prépare sa liste les républicains
prépare la leur enfin je veux pas y est
tous les noms des partis qui préparent
leur liste monde immense nous non
seulement nous y pensons mais en plus
nous allons préparer notre liste avec
d'autres c'est plus que jamais parce que
l'europe c'est un besoin et un besoin
important on a vu la crise qui pointe et
notamment sur les phénomènes migratoires
on suivra tout ça merci beaucoup avec
nous pour refaire cette semaine
politique et parlementaire merci de
givenchy merci thibault et recevront la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
2 par le mc do
[Musique]